You ready for this?
Yeah.
Uh, by this logic, any characters with
ambitions is a satanic character. Mario
wants to do something with his life, but
is told he can't succeed by everyone,
even his own parents. In the end, he
finally proves himself. Also, Bowser is
literally forcing Peach to marry him
despite not even knowing the other uh
each other and doesn't care who he
hurts. Now look, there's 44 thumbs up on
that comment. So there's 44 other people
that agree like um yeah, I think they're
reaching or whatever. But okay, so the
logic here is because Bowser is
forcefully trying to marry Peach,
this can't be a God figure.
But the whole point of what we're saying
is this isnosticism. This is the way
Satan would tell his side of the story.
how he'll describe God to you. God is a
tyrant,
right?
God is trying to kill anyone who doesn't
worship him, that he's, you know, if God
is really coming to save the bride, then
he's going to paint it like he's
forcefully taking her against her will.
Yeah, that's exactly right. And uh I I
think it's fascinating that when you uh
want to present something that's the
opposite, you force that idea onto other
people so that you present it as if it's
a forced love.
And uh the the characteristics presented
by Bowser or Koopa, King Koopa as they
call him, we're going to see here in a
second. And we're gonna actually I mean
it's it's blatantly obvious who Bowser
is portraying here and who Mario as the
underdog is portraying. By the way, who
is the underdog in the great
controversy?
Well, that would be Satan. He wants to
get the sympathy. Look, I was born this
way. I can't help it that I'm a fallen
angel and yet now I'm banished out of
heaven. I can't go to heaven because you
made me this way, God. See, this is the
the sympathy for the devil story that we
see in so many movies. Like uh Ralph,
you know, he's at the with Bowser, by
the way. He's at the bad guys anonymous
meeting and Bowser's right there with
him and and you know, he wants to be
good, but they're telling him, "No, you
can't be good. You were made to be bad."
Okay, so check this out. We're going to
go another comment here. We're going to
go over a few of these comments because
I I really want to uh punch this home.
This is interesting.
Pause that.
Don't follow the game's lore. That's
what I said. Yeah, I quoted that. Don't
follow the game's lore. The whole point
of Mario Odyssey was Bowser wanting to
marry Peach on the moon. Absolutely
right. He's right about this. But I
never said that that wasn't part of the
lore,
right?
I said that not part of the lore was
having Peach be the main character. I
mean, she's practically the main
character throughout this whole thing.
She is the one pushing forward. I mean,
what is that? To me, that's a woke
agenda.
That's not just, you know, let's let's
make Mario uh the side character. She
actually says
he's not anything. He's nothing. He's
not important.
And so, she almost gets more screen time
than him. So, I think that's that's
that's we're going to see more about
that in a second. But,
um let's move on to the next comment
here.
Let me play this.
All Mario wants is to be something
bigger, better, and higher than the rest
of us. That's what me. That's what I
said. Yeah.
He started his own plumbing business. He
never showed any sinful ambition
throughout the whole movie. He was more
or less the underdog character. We
already commented on the underdog
character.
Yeah.
But did he show any sinful ambitions?
Well, I didn't see the movie, but I saw
him sneaking past the guards to get into
the kingdom. That sounds like a sneaky
sounds like a type of lying to me. I
mean, he was trying to be uh forcing his
way and and pretending to be he was part
of this this kingdom. That's exactly the
thing Satan does at the end of time.
Actually, in our lifetime, he is
infiltrated into some of the churches
and pretended to be a part of it. So,
he's got characteristics of people in
this part of it. And so, that's exactly
what Mario is doing. We already brought
that out in the in the video, but
if we look at pop culture media through
the lens of the Bible, you see it over
and over and over. I mean, this the way
you started it out, there's a bride, a a
beast, uh, you know, the end of the
world destroying and fire. All these
elements are there, but the characters
are twisted and they're put in the wrong
place. And, um, that's the way Satan
would tell the story.
Something you said made me think about
that, but
Yeah. No, that's that's exactly it. So,
is it playing from the beginning again?
Yeah. Okay, let's let's move on to the
next one here. It says um
here we go.
Interesting how some people are stuck on
this story is in everything. This is
this was a great comment. I I I really
appreciate this. I if you notice I
crossed out everyone's name even if they
said a good comment because I wanted to
uh you know not reveal or or dox anyone
as they say right but um she says this
is story this story is in everything
people say it's the most basic story
line in all media you guys are reaching
but that's the point she says
why is it why is this basic plotline so
pervasive
even across cultures why are these shows
for adults, children, doesn't matter.
Always ending with humanity banding
together to defend our existence against
a tyrannical god or godlike figure.
What exactly is the point to tell this
one story over and over and over again
just with different scenery? Is it
because we really aren't that creative?
I mean, we got a lot of creativity. a
lot of creativity, but is it because
we're not that creative
and and simply can't uh can't have only
one story to tell or is it because there
is a point to ingraining the story in
people's minds? Either way, this should
catch your attention.
Yep. So, I mean, I just think it's
interesting. This is best
post-apocalyptic movies in 2022.
Uh, Moonfall, Last Survivors,
Black Crab, Borderlands,
uh, A Quiet Place, Dune for D. So many
movies are about the end of the world.
The crudes is about the end of the
world. Lego movie about the end of the
world. Literally, every movie that comes
out, it's like you coming soon to
appear, the end of the world. We need to
band together to fight against the
asteroid, the UFO, Thanos. It's always
some threat from out there is coming to
earth and we need to fight together
against it. It's the same story over and
over. And like she said, that's the
whole point. People are saying that this
is a reach or you're making something
out of nothing. No, we need to be
thinking where is this story coming
from? Why? When you see a common thread,
when you see the same template over and
over and over, you can't say, "Oh, it's
just coincidence. Oh, it's just random.
These are just mindless entertainment."
No, there's a pattern here. And when
there's a pattern, you want to find out
where did that pattern come from.
And that's what we're doing. That's what
if you scroll through our channel,
you're going to see it over and over and
over again. And most of the time, people
agree with the videos we're saying that
do that.
But there's something different about
Mario that makes people resilient,
resistant to receive that message.
And I'm just going to do a couple more
of these, but I think it's it's it's
interesting uh that we go through this.
Uh let me see here. Don't follow the
game lore.
And let's move on to this one. The
ending with the blue star made it
definitive that the entire movie had
anostic and other subtle sub subliminal
messages that children are vulnerable
to. M
even most parents who are naive and
think that it's just an innocent movie
when the makers of the movie know
beforehand to make it appear
light-hearted
instead of making it obvious that
there's something sinister going on.
Nothing left but you and the infinite
void.
That's what the star said at the end of
the movie.
Wow.
Is some of what the blue star said at
the end. If that sits well with you as
normal, you need to critically think
about what you are feeding your mind.
Wow.
So, you know what I think about that's
interesting about that is um that they
got rid of Bowser. And we're going to
see in a moment that Bowser more than
just what we proved in that video is
truly the portrayal of God
and uh and getting rid of God, what is
there left? Nothing. Infinite void. And
he said, "Is that is this happiness?"
Wow. What? Okay. I you know, I'll be
honest. I didn't even really understand
what the blue star thing was about
except that it was just like this dark,
you know, ending on some kind of dark
note. But that makes a lot of sense.
You killed God. You're in an infinite
void.
And it's coming from a star, which the
Bible says are angels,
right? Right. Yeah. Exactly. The Bible
calls angels in Revelation. I'm going to
move on uh through some of these real
quick to try to get to the meat of the
program. What do you think about this
right here? Uh,
pause that. What do you think about this
um this uh uh uh what's it called? This
picture.
So, this was a game on the Super
Nintendo uh RPG game, and it's called
Legend of the Seven Stars.
Seven Stars. Where have I heard that
before? Uh let's search the Bible for
it. So
yeah,
if I look up the King James and I type
seven stars, I see Revelation 1:16 and
it says, "And he talking about Christ
had in his right hand seven stars. And
out of his mouth went a sharp two-edged
sword." Wait a minute. Show that
picture.
Yeah. There we go.
Wait a minute. A sharp two-edged sword.
Are we seeing a sword in the We see
seven stars. We see a sharp two-edged
sword. This is coming right from the
book of Revelation. You see the sword in
the background. So that's Bowser's
castle. Bowser's palace has the sharp
two-edged sword.
I didn't either. This is all just like
we're learning together, guys. We're
researching together. So the Jesus holds
seven stars in his hands. Out of his
mouth went a sharp two-edged sword. And
his countenance was that of the sun
shining in strength. Uh, Revelation 1:20
also says, "The mystery of the seven
stars which thou saw on thy right hand
are the seven golden candlesticks. The
seven stars are the angels of the seven
churches."
Revelation 2:1 says, "The seven stars in
his right hand or these things saith he
that holdeth the seven stars in his
right hand." In Revelation 3:1 says,
"These things saith he that hath the
seven spirits of God and the seven
stars." So, we know that Jesus has the
seven stars in his hands and they are
seven angels.
Right. Right. And um let me bring this
back to here real quick. And and if you
think that's reaching, just wait till
the end of the program. We're going to
go through item by item by item item
showing you that not only is it pre
prevalent in the movie that just was
released, but also in the in-game part
of it, too.
What what I thought was interesting was
the comment I saw over and over was
like, "This isn't this isn't something
new. This came from the games. All the
games is the same thing. The Bowser was,
you know, he came down from the sky to
try and marry the princess." And it's
like, okay, that doesn't discredit the
information. It just further proves that
this has been going on as long as the
games, you know.
Right. Yeah. And I think what's
fascinating about it is the princess
that you mentioned.
Where does she live?
She lives in a perfect paradise in the
Bible, a woman is considered a um a
church.
Yep.
And so
to expound on you, you mentioned that in
the video. You had a good verse. I
actually never what was the verse?
Oh, I don't remember off the top of my
head.
Husbands, love your wives even as Christ
loves the church. can create more time
and then just make it
um it also you know in the Bible he's
coming he's the bridegroom coming for
his bride and and if you read the Old
Testament God's people are always he's
always saying that they've gone a
whoring after strange gods because we're
in a marriage and if you if you worship
God and then you worship another god
then you're you're whoring yourself to
someone else this is this is what we're
talking about the bride the church the
woman we are the bride of Christ
right absolutely Absolutely. And check
this out. This is from the in-game.
Wait, is this game or video? I don't
remember.
That's from the movie. I think
this from the movie. So,
I think look at this. It's got stained
glass in it right here. What What is
What is all this this stained glass of
the princess? Now, let's move on to this
next picture here. This
Where do you find a stained glass
window?
Oo,
we actually asked chat GBT just to see
what it would say. And it said churches,
synagogues,
other places of worship. Like you find
stained glass windows in cathedrals,
churches, synagogues. And so it's
interesting that the woman, the bride,
the princess. If we are the bride of
the prince of peace, that makes us a
Yeah, it makes us the woman of princess.
Yeah, princess. Yeah, it's Wow, that's
hard for me to think about.
Princess bride.
Oh. Oh, look at this. What's on the
other side? It's like clouds. Oh,
so you have, you know, this is the God
is the coming on the clouds, the kingdom
in the clouds, you know,
that's fascinating. Okay, check this
out. This next video clip, I don't have
my notes in front of me anymore, but um
let's comment on this real quick. This
this really blew me away.
Let this go through.
Some princess napping and destructive
tendencies aside, Bowser is a great
father. You can't create more time.
Great father.
Yeah, he he's a great father, they said.
Okay. So, Bowser is a great father. Who
else is a good good father? Is who you
are. God is our good good father. Uh I
think it's interesting. We're we're
gonna see other videos where they say
that Bowser is really the only father
figure in the whole franchise of Mario.
Yeah. I'm going to pause right here for
a second. Can you find me the the the
channel changer? I can't hear the audio.
I see it right there. I had it in front
of me, but someone took it from me.
Uh yeah, you know what to me.
Yeah, because I can't hear what's going
on. But I remember this clip and we're
like, "Oh yeah, father, you guys can
hear it, I think, but we can't hear it."
So, let's go ahead and keep going with
this.
Yeah, if you guys hear the clips, give a
little thumbs up.
Yeah,
take it. And so he does to check in on
his son's chores during Mario Rabbit's
Kingdom Battle. And no doubt an effort
to teach the little man
turtle monster of responsibility,
honesty, and the ability to juggle
fighting dual plumber brothers, all the
while keeping a tidy room. And
so, I think that's interesting. And
here's why. because Bowser is the only
the only the only uh character in the
whole film that is portrayed as a
father. And so he's fixing his his uh uh
his uh his son, you know, helping his
son's room and he has a whole family. I
mean, granted, at the very beginning of
the film, we did see for the first time
practically the the uh father uh and
family of Mario and Luigi, but they
weren't main characters. We're talking
about the main characters of the film.
Mario, Princess, Bowser, you know,
things like that that we've seen
throughout the whole whole franchise.
Um,
who is I mean, out of those main
characters,
I'm asking you, is is it is is uh Bowser
considered a father?
He's a father. He's a king. His
kingdom's always up in the sky
somewhere. Like,
there's so much here.
So, okay. So, that's that's fascinating.
But, uh, let's continue down.
How can you think this guy isn't
awesome? He's the crowned ruler of an
entire kingdom. Super tough and strong.
Has access to the Mushroom Kingdom's
most advanced technology and most
powerful magics. Can travel through
space and time at will, and all the
while remains a devoted and loving
father.
Huh. Huh. I I want to say that this this
guy, Game Theorist, he has over 17
million subscribers. That video had
millions of views. Are Are you going to
put the comments on there?
The comments of the I didn't see any
comments. Okay, so the comments on that
video were like, whoa, it's amazing like
how deep the storyline is, like how the
the uh the creators, they went to the
lore and all this stuff and they were
these people are saying the exact
opposite of what's happening on our
channel.
Yeah.
Because we're coming at it from the
angle like this offends God. Whereas if
it's oh wait, there really it really is
deep, but it doesn't offend God. So
I might I might bring those comments up
if you when you talk next. But I think
what's interesting is exactly what you
said. They were saying, "Man, I can't
believe that these these uh these are
integrating real life scenarios and
biblical ideas into their films. That's
so great." They were saying and we were
saying, "Hey, they're integrating real
life scenarios and and biblical
scenarios into the films." And people
are saying, "Oh, you're reaching
reaching." Yeah. Yeah. It is
interesting, man.
So, let's go back to the the next next
one. Oh. Oh, and I also wanted to bring
out there there was a lot going on in
this one. He is the magician.
Oh, did you not play more of those?
No, I mean I No, I that was just in this
one clip alone. Whoops, wrong one.
In that one clip alone, it talks about
him being uh access to all the uh Oh,
let me just just go through that one
more time. I mean, there's a lot in
sitting on the throne.
Super tough and strong. Has access to
the Mushroom Kingdom's most advanced
technology. And
so he has access to most advanced
technologies. Okay, technologies
technically and God has technologies.
They might look advanced technologies to
us, but he's created them. I mean, if
you think about it, a muscle is a
technology, right? So, if he created
beings, we are the thing he created.
Yeah.
I'm going to call that a technology of
God.
Most powerful magics can travel through
space and time at will and all the while
can travel through.
I mean, what
travel through time and space.
So, I didn't know that. I didn't know
that about the game until I watched this
video.
Yeah. So, we're learning even more.
Mhm. So, he can travel through space and
time, and it's going to go on and
explain that a little bit further as we
get down in there. But, isn't that a I
don't think Mario can do that. Why would
Mario be considered
the the the hero character? Yeah, the
hero character can travel through space
and time. So, I Mario is obviously the
underdog.
Yeah.
So, I I think that's
remains a devoted and loving father.
And there we go again. A loving father.
Loving father.
Okay. So, let's check out this next next
clip.
And I don't know about you, but in every
single castle of Bowsers I've ever seen,
there's a ton of gold coins. Now, if you
can make the argument that coins are
just reoccurring items in every Mario
level ever, then why does Bowser have a
solid gold train in
Okay, so pause it right there. He not
only is he the wealthiest guy, he he
comes in the clouds, he has a a a castle
on a rock that's not carved out uh
that's not carved by hands, right? It's
all jagged and everything. He has Look
at this. The train solid gold train has
a ton of money in it and it's going on
top of roads made of gold.
That's right. It's when you read the
when you read about heaven, it's got
streets of gold.
Interesting. We're just adding more
evidence here. You know, if people think
that video is a reach, then think of all
that that was shown in the video and
then add this to it. We're just piling
up the evidence.
Um, where does Bowser live? in a a
mountain of fire. We know that God lives
where the fiery stones are, the mount of
of the Lord. Somebody actually there was
a comment that said, "I can't believe
little light would take
just pull it down."
They said, um,
I thought the whole light was coming
down on you.
They basically said Little Light are the
only people that could take a fireb
breathing dragon who uh lives in the
realm of hell basically and call him
God. Look, we are we're we're following
a bunch of caricatures that the devil
made. The devil doesn't wear the devil
doesn't have horns and he doesn't live
in hell. Where who lives where the fire
is? That's God. He they followed him as
a pillar of fire. He came as a burning
bush. He's going to return and destroy
the earth with fire. He is a consuming
fire.
Right? When Satan was in heaven, it says
that he walked around well Satan
technically Lucifer at the at the time.
When he was in heaven, he was uh the
Bible says he walked around in the fiery
stones.
Yeah.
The stones of God. And so these these
things are uh definitely God is a
consuming fire, the Bible says. And so I
I think that's it's it's pretty obvious,
but um let's continue down the the the
rabbit hole, shall we?
Mhm.
His likeness carrying around hundreds of
gold coins. And don't even tell me
Bowser shipping riches is something new.
Back in Mario 3, Bowser had entire
airships literally stuffed with gold
coins that Mario
So Bowser's airship is also still in the
sky. Fascinating. I'm just saying more
in the sky stuff that Bowser has.
I know. That's interesting. His his
kingdom is in the sky.
Just pirate it.
A Toad informs us that Bowser created
the painting worlds to keep the power
stars hidden away to trap the Toads and
Peach. We can confirm that the castle is
placed on Earth and the painting worlds
are not on Earth and can be accessed
through transcending boundaries. Gods
have the power to create worlds. This
would make Bowser a god.
Wa!
I didn't say that. I didn't say it.
You want me to play it again?
Yeah. Yeah, he made morons.
He He made apparently. I mean, I didn't
I like I said, I didn't know that until
we started researching through that. So,
let's let's play that again and see
exactly what that was all about. Listen
listen, everyone. A toad informs us that
Bowser created the painting worlds to
keep the power stars hidden away to trap
the Toads and Peach. We can confirm that
the castle is placed on Earth and the
painting worlds are not on Earth and can
be accessed through transcending
boundaries. Gods have the power to
create worlds. This would make Bowser a
god. I I think that's fascinating. So,
I'm going to pause it right there just
for a second. The um and this is another
channel showing that this is uh he's
fighting a god.
Yeah,
there aren't multiple gods. There might
be little G gods, but
but he's pretending to be the god coming
from heaven.
Yeah. And just to clarify the other clip
where he was talking about the train and
all that, that guy was making a case
that Bowser is this Japanese like turtle
dragon god thing. Um, but that's the
thing, he's a god. And we know that
there's only one god. Any other god is a
counterfeit. But the fact that he
can time travel at will, he can make
worlds, he is in the sky, he's coming to
earth to take his bride
and destroy the rest with the lake of
fire. Like, dude,
there there there's no other way to look
at this.
You can't say that that's Satan. Satan
is not coming on the clouds to take his
bride and destroy the rest of fire,
right?
He's not doing that.
In the lake of fire, all
in the lake of fire.
Okay. So, you want to you want to see a
nail in the cuff? And this is what I
really really was impressed by.
Um, this is the show that I used to
watch. Remember I said at the beginning
in the countdown, this is, um, the
original series that I used to watch as
a kid when I was six or seven years old.
The brothers. The brothers. The
brothers.
And so, uh, this this is one that I
didn't remember, but apparently this is
what happened because this is exactly
what it looks like. Um, listen to what
they say. This blew my mind. And check
this out.
1,00 BC.
[Music]
We've arrived in pyramid land where we'd
heard the mushroom people were in real
trouble.
King Koopa had appointed himself Pharaoh
and was forcing everyone to live by a
set of evil laws.
Look, it's Koopa's 10 commandments.
This time that Kirby Koopa's gone too
far. Come on. We've got to free the
mushroom people from Koopa's terrible
coupe man.
Okay. What?
Free the mushroom people from from Okay.
So, not only did he come in the sky to
save his bride, he's a he's a god
basically. I mean, he's created worlds
and he's coming
and he's given the commandments which
looks like two tables of stone with 10
things subscribed on them. Who does this
remind you of?
Like he's making everyone follow these
evil laws.
Dude, this is pretty clear, man. Uh
yeah, if you guys still have questions,
I'm I'm still waiting for all the people
that said we're reaching.
I'm There was at least one person, maybe
two, who said they were unsubscribing
from our channel
because we pointed out that Mario is
fighting against a powerful god. that's
coming to earth to destroy the world
with fire and to take his bride. Why?
Why are you unsubscribing? Because we
point out what's literally there.
Yeah.
It's this is this is emotions. These are
Look, I'm going to be completely honest
with everybody. I haven't I I've been
working here for 5 years. And in the
beginning, you know, I might have still
watched a movie here and there and then
I h I lost interest in that stuff. And
now when I watch a trailer, it repulses
me. I see a trailer that's glamorizing
the occult and it and it just there's
nothing about it that appeals to me. But
when Mario came out,
yeah,
there was a big part of me that was
like, "Wow, I hope I can watch this. I
hope there's nothing in it because it it
was nostalgic to me." And I like Mario
and I was like, I hope there's no LGBT
stuff. I hope there's no magic and
sorcery and and now I cannot watch this
movie in good conscience knowing that
they're literally making God the
villain. I just can't. And I'm I'm
telling you this because I'm having to
fight against my own flesh. This isn't
just us saying, you know, I understand
the battle. This is a real battle of of
trying to die to self. And
right,
I understand the the nostalgia that
comes with it. I grew up on Mario as
well and I wanted to see the movie and I
even recently thought, hey, maybe those
games I could play them with my daughter
because the they're Mario, you know, and
now I'm looking into the games. I've
never played Paper Mario before. And I
thought it looks pretty innocent and I
recently bought a Wii so I could play
some of these sport games and stuff. And
um it says
the story opens with a a place that lies
far beyond the sky and far above the
clouds called Star Haven. Within the
sanctuary of Star Haven, what
I'm reading this for the first time lies
the star rod which can grant any wish.
The seven star spirits.
The seven spirits that we just read
about in Revelation, the seven star
spirits use it this artifact to watch
over and protect the mushroom kingdom
until one day Bowser and Cammy Koopa
appear in the sanctuary.
Bowser's appearing in the sanctuary.
Okay,
Satan can't do that. Bowser shatters the
protective seal over the star rod and
grabs it in hopes uh using its power to
defeat Mario. the the star spirits are
then trapped inside cards by Cramy. I'll
have to read more of this. There was
there was some of this that was just
like this is just in-your-face stuff.
The stars are basically uh trapped by by
Bowser. So angels are are being bound by
God. Think Satan's telling the story
that that that God keeps angels
prisoners.
[Laughter]
It really floores me when they said
sanctuary.
Yeah.
And I mean
God is in the sanctuary. We are told at
the end of time, which is not what this
was talking about, that that Satan will
appear in the most in in the holy place.
And it talks about that in the poetic
language in in Daniel Revelation. But I
I think it's it's fascinating. It's
fascinating. There's such
so much lore
engulfing this game. And it's even
though it's pulled from a not
necessarily Christian roots,
it's still got a lot of Christianes in
it. So I Why is that happening? That
that's
that's fascinating. Is it is it just
because someone, you know, thought, "Oh,
I'm going to put that in there because
that'd be funny." Or is that
is that supernatural?
It's got to be supernatural. This came
from Japan. There's less than 1% of
Christianity in Japan. And we've seen
this. We talk about this in the anime
documentary. how much Christian themes
are in anime. Neon Genesis Evangelion
literally means a new gospel
interpretation of the Genesis and
they're fighting against angels who are
who are sent by God to destroy half the
world. Uh and then now we're at the
place where we have the seven deadly
sins who fight against the Ten
Commandments.
How does this get into Japan?
They're being inspired by something
inspirited. M m
we believe that not every director and
writer are sitting around some table in
a smoke filled room saying how can we
deceive the Christians but we believe
that they're openly telling us hey I got
this script from a dream Cameron Avatar
I got the script from a dream Terminator
got the script from a dream Harry Potter
got the script script from a dream
actors that wasn't me out there I was
channeling a spirit Malcolm Den Denzel
Washington was playing Malcolm X. He
kept on going. That wasn't in the
script. They kept it in the movie.
Yeah.
So, literally, while he's channeling a
spirit that was in the movie, you're
being entertained by that spirit.
I'm just glancing at the comments right
now. Some guy named Super Quote, which
is an awesome name by the way, because
it looks like Super Chat
Super Quote
says, "Uh, Mikey, if you see my comment,
look up." He quotes this. Okay. N64
Princess Peach Castle Voyer. V O Y E R.
It's
uh it's he said it's a Masonic lodge.
Oh, yep.
Sun motif with black and white checkered
floor.
So Nintendo 64 Princess Castle. What?
Uh N64
um um um uh Yeah, look it up on YouTube
because um N64 Princess Peach Castle. B
O Y E R. That's what he says to look up.
Uh, super quote. Thanks, super quote.
We'll check that out. Um,
I mean, I think that clip you showed had
some of that in there. So, I'm I'm
seeing um
Yeah, the the castle is is straight up
Freemasonic. You go you walk in, there's
the checkered floors. You got u all the
pentagrams spinning around the the coins
with the stars on them. Um, you look up
and there's the sun motif. If you look
down or maybe the sun is down there,
too. All that stuff. It's all in the
Masonic lodges.
Interesting, huh? Is that was that N?
That was N64. Yeah, we saw that in the
video. That was N64. Wandered around
there and
and had that going there.
Fascinating. I'm looking at the comments
right now.
Um I thought we'd get to the the live
comments instead of going back to the uh
the old comments because
it'd be interesting just now that we
have a good group of people in here.
Yeah. I'd love for someone to tell us
how we're reaching, what the truth is.
how this isn't what we're seeing it
because
you know there was a there was a lot of
some of the people then the comments on
that video really brought out some other
good points too like when he was coming
with fire to to earth it was it looked
like a big mountain you know an upside
down mountain and in the book of Daniel
it says that the final kingdom will be
Christ returning like a stone cut
without hands to smash every other
kingdom and take over the world
I mean there's so much symbology in
there. You you mentioned that his house
was founded on the rock, but it's also
um Yeah, the kingdom. Oh. Oh, I know
what I wanted to show you in Paper
Mario.
Mhm.
It said that I think it was Paper Mario.
It might have been another one, but it
says that Bowser's kingdom went
underground under the princess's castle
and lifted it up into the heavens like a
rapture. He literally took the whole
church to heaven.
I mean, come on, guys. But he's the bad
guy. He's the villain. Mario needs to
save her from heaven.
Oh my goodness. So, he Okay, so I mean,
I'm convinced. I was convinced before,
but
yeah,
I think we've we've uh
overstepped the bounds on this. This is
fascinating. If someone wants to produce
a counterpoint to this, they'd have to
go through every single point we've made
here. And it's just impossible to to
refute
how obvious it is that Bowser is
portrayed as God that Mario has to
defeat.
Yep. I believe it 100%. Um
I didn't see any really
somebody says I agree 100% of what you
all are saying. Mhm.
You know, I I just think it's important
for us to do stuff like this, you know,
to to
I don't want us to ever put out a video
that seems like there's holes in it that
it's not a solid point and then somebody
say, "I'm leaving your channel because
now you're just making stuff up."
Not making stuff up.
Yeah. So, we want to come on here. We
want to hear your input. We really do.
We're open-minded. We're I mean, you
have to be openminded to see this kind
of stuff. We're open-minded. We want to
hear your opinions. We want to We
definitely don't want you to leave. And
we want to connect with you guys and we
want to be able to share, hey, there's
more than what we put in the video.
There's more evidence to this thing.
We're not just grasping at straws and
reaching.
This was just the what we covered. What
I covered in that video was just what
was portrayed
that really stuck out to me. There was
so much more we could have said in the
games. I mean, there's there's been
games since the 80s.
Yeah.
80s, maybe even 70s. I forget when it
started, but
it was it's it's been going on forever.
And so, we could go through, if we had
time, every single game and say, "Hey,
look, this is what the Lord says. This
is what is happening. This is obvious
what we know
is Gnostic." Wendy uh Parker says,
"Nostic religion always flips the
script, calling God evil and those who
oppose him as good." Yeah,
she's 100% right.
There was um just trying to think. There
was something else in the Paper Mario
thing. Yeah, I looked in I just looked
into the Paper Mario thing cuz I was I
was tempted to buy it and was like,
"Hey, if it's Oh, in one of the scenes,
you go to a fortune teller, a ghost with
a pyramid, a floating spinning gold
pyramid that says, "Do you want me to
read your fortune? Yes or no?" So, I
mean, even even that aspect, there's,
you know, the ghosts are bad guys. Okay,
you can argue that. I think the witch in
Paper Mario was a good guy, though. It
was like this Koopa riding a broom
flying around and for some reason I kept
seeing it talk to Mario like it was a
good guy. I don't know. I'm not Don't
like hold that against me if that's
wrong, but it looked it appeared as if
the witch was good.
Look, we got a comment. Honestly, you
guys must be so lumber. I don't know
what lumber is from the amount of
stretching
to get limber limber from to get the
results you got from Mario K movie. See,
we always get these comments, but no one
ever actually says what is so long.
I would love for you to just tell us
what was what was the reach? What was
the stretch, please?
It's it's an emotional thing.
It is.
They they they want to uh
I'm right here on Wikip uh Paper Mario.
Phantom Bowser's Castle in the Sky.
Bowser's sky castle. Mhm.
I mean, you just when you're the bad guy
has a castle in the sky. He's and it's
surrounded with fire and he's coming to
take the church, the woman. I just don't
see how you can see it any other way.
There's just no way. There's no way to
make that Satan. That's not Satan. He's
not coming for the bride and to destroy
the rest with fire and to take her into
the sky. That's just not happening. Mhm.
Mhm. I got I got that's the end of my
presentation, but I thought we would uh
kind of look at the comments, just look
and see what uh what other people are
saying on here. I can't see anyone else
that is disagreeing.
So, I mean, this is your time to shine.
Yeah.
But, um
Star Road, I mean, the angel road.
Interesting.
You're still finding stuff, huh?
Yeah.
Now, what do you what do you say? Should
we continue or should we uh we uh try to
research some more?
I think it's I think it's good that
we're seeing that people are agreeing.
Um and we got 114 thumbs ups in here.
And I I just hope that if anybody was
skeptical that maybe this added a little
more to it. I mean, Bowser's writing the
the commandments and uh
yeah, it's all there, man. Do your own
research, too. We encourage you. Hey,
prove us wrong. That's what I wanted to
do. I I was telling Brad before we got
on camera, I said when I wanted to, you
know, there was a part of me that was
like, maybe I can prove this wrong. You
know, I want to look up. Maybe Paper
Mario is safe or whatever. And the more
I looked, the more I found. And I'm
like, no.
Look, I It's a struggle for us, too. I
mean, when it comes to things that we
grew up on.
So,
absolutely.
Lauren says, "Hi, Mikey and Brad." Hey,
Lauren C. Always good to see you. Hey,
Joy. Hey, Wendy Parker.
These are people I I'm familiar with.
Coupe man. Say what?
That's right. Those
evil rules. Always the evil rules.
Yeah. So that that ties into Mario
saying, you know, I'm just so sick of
people telling me what to do. Well, in
the cartoon, he said, oh, he's trying to
make these people follow these evil
rules,
but he's just a plumber.
That's right.
He's the underdog. Yeah. And often times
the underdog is is not the good guy.
Yeah.
And so, but people love an underdog
story. And you got to wonder if that's
if that's uh what do they call that? Is
it art imitating life or life imitating
art? Are we are we changed by what we
have we made ourselves like to see the
underdog
or uh is that a perversion maybe because
you know obviously the best
uh type of uh person wouldn't be the
underdog it'd be God right God is not an
underdog God God is God so have we
trained oursel to like the underdog is
that Hollywood's one of Hollywood's
missions I don't know I just thoughts
come to my No.
Well, we hope you guys enjoyed this.
This was edifying to you. If you did,
give it a big thumbs up. It really helps
out.
And I thought Brad was going to take
over from there.
I was looking for the button. I got I
got to also do the the streaming, too.
So, I was Oh, he's ending. He's ending.
Quick, hit the button.
We appreciate every single one of you,
and we do appreciate if you share, like,
and subscribe. If you do have someone
that's like, I saw the video and I don't
like it. Send them this video. Yeah,
we want more comments on this one
because we are looking at them. We see
every single one and we want to know
exactly what you think about it. Not
just you're reaching, you're reaching.
We want to know exactly what we're
reaching at so we can improve.
We love you guys. Take care.
Yep. Amen.